Speaker 1: Today we're going to be speaking
with Professor Paul Slovic, who teaches psychology
at the University of Oregon and also is president
of the Decision Sciences Research Institute
in Eugene, Oregon.
Really great having you on.
I appreciate your time.
Speaker 2: Thank you, David.
Good to be with you.
Speaker 1: So maybe to start with, we make
decisions as humans about risk reward all
the time in our everyday lives.
I think with many of the types of decisions
we make, we have the feeling that we're pretty
good at assessing the level of risk when we
are undertaking these decisions.
Generally speaking, are humans as good as
we think at assessing risk or not?
Speaker 2: It depends if we're in a situation
that's familiar to us that we've, you know,
experienced before and and learn from our
mistakes and our successes, then I think we're
pretty, pretty good.
If it's a novel situation where the stakes
are high, then we are a challenge, particularly
if the likelihood of something very good or
very bad happening is is small.
And we have to kind of figure out, well, you
know, how do we how do we deal with this is
a risk that we're willing to take and that
it's beneficial for us to take.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, maybe to think through
an example, lots of people are afraid of flying
on commercial aircraft and there's all sorts
of different statistics that are often presented
by those who extoll the safety record of commercial
aircraft.
And sometimes they say, here is your risk
of death per million passenger miles flown
or the chance of a fatal crash is, you know,
some small number.
And, you know, if you told me there was a
1% chance of a fatal crash, I'm not getting
on the airplane.
I know that that's quite high.
I've taken hundreds of flights.
Right.
So one out of 100 sounds very high.
But when the numbers are smaller, it does
become more difficult to think of what that
really means for us, doesn't it?
Speaker 2: Absolutely.
And more generally, the numbers really don't
communicate very well with us.
What's more important is our is our experience,
you know, and have we flown and everything's
gone.
Okay.
And and what do we hear on our on television
or media?
Has it been a recent crash or has it been
has there been something that's happened that
leads us to have less trust in the safety
of of airliners?
Like, if there's a like the 737 a few years
ago were mysteriously crashing and and people
didn't know exactly what was going on or that
was scary.
So so all of these things are a factor that
affects our what we call our feeling of risk.
Because most of the time, we we take risks
depending on how we how we feel about it,
whether whether we're worried or scared, as
opposed to whether the statistics, you know,
seem okay to us.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: I mean, thinking of the airplane
example, you often hear you're more likely
to get into an accident and die driving to
the airport than on the plane.
But it certainly doesn't feel that way, I
think, to lots of people.
So that seems to be the psychological layer
to it.
Speaker 2: Right.
So there is a lot of things going on there.
When you're when you're driving, you feel,
you know, you're in control of the risk and
you are partially in control, although not
as much as you think you are, because there
are other drivers on the roads that there
may be some bad conditions on the roadway
and so forth.
But you feel in control when you're on the
plane.
You know that.
You know you're not controlling that plane.
And so you have to trust the pilots and the
system.
These days, many of the planes are being flown
by computer, but it doesn't you know, we don't
see that.
Speaker 1: When it comes to something like
COVID 19.
There's been a lot of interesting websites
where you can plug in a variety of different
data about yourself and about a scenario in
which you're thinking of putting yourself.
And the idea is it will spit something out
to you objective that you can then use to
determine whether it's a safe enough situation
for you or not.
So, of course, we know age and preexisting
conditions are risk factors for getting very
sick with COVID.
We also know that it spreads more easily indoors
than outdoors.
And I did one of these before our interview,
and I can keep feeding information.
Right.
How many people am I going to be around?
Are they vaccinated?
Am I indoors or outdoors?
Will the encounter be one, two or three hour,
all these different things?
And then it tells me your risk as a three
out of ten, it seems like it's very difficult
to really turn that into actionable intelligence
in a sense.
I mean, it's it's so detailed, but at the
same time, what do I do with that information?
Speaker 2: Absolutely.
But first, I'm not sure how many people use
it.
These sites.
Yeah, most of the time we're just operating
again on our experience and and how much how
important it is for us to do, you know, to
have this meeting or to to go to this event,
this sort of thing.
And and again, we're using we're using our
feelings more than any statistics.
Sure.
We know that in general, if we're older or
we have a preexisting condition that makes
us vulnerable, that we have to be more careful.
And I think people are sensitive to that and
are trying to monitor that and and be careful.
But I think more generally, we as we see,
you know, very few people are taking precautions
right now.
We see a few people wearing masks.
And and it's like it's like it doesn't exist
anymore.
Even though COVID is still still quite prevalent.
You know, we're told that the the effects
are not as serious as the early versions.
And and we feel pretty comfortable going about
our business as though things were normal,
even though they're not.
But again, it's not a really a matter of statistics.
It's a matter of how we feel about it.
And the thing about our feelings is sometimes
they they deceive us.
You know, we can't always trust them.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
The interesting thing about the the back to
normal COVID feelings that you talk about,
you know, I don't remember if it's Daniel
Dennett or Daniel Kahneman who had a particular
heuristic that they wrote about.
But there's this kind of familiarity where
once COVID is no longer something new and
we've been living with the risk for a period
of time, even if we have not necessarily been
actually engaging in risky behavior ourselves,
it sort of becomes background in a sense where
this is now part of the status quo of life.
And it seems that may allow people to feel
as though the risk has lessened, even though
it really hasn't.
Maybe we've just gotten more used to it.
Speaker 2: Yes, that that definitely happens.
So I'm we're pretty comfortable with the seasonal
flu, you know, and even though it could be
serious and a lot of people got very sick
and some died, you know, it was something
that we we lived with and became kind of normalized.
So these things become normalized unless something
special happens.
Just like gun violence.
I mean, gun violence in this country has become
normalized.
But every once in a while, we have some sort
of unusual and horrific event like we have
in recent weeks in Highland Park, Illinois,
and Buffalo.
That shakes us out of that and says, wait
a minute, you know, this is different.
And we start to pay attention for a while.
And then and then it's sort of our concern
fades away.
There's sort of a window of when we're suddenly
awake to the problem and concerned about it
and want something done.
And then and then over time, that window starts
to close.
So.
So, again, this is the way our feelings go,
you know, that that these events can shake
us out of our, what we call our psychic numbing,
at least for a while.
And that's the window when action needs to
be taken, it seems.
Speaker 1: Also, there's the other side where,
for example, after 911, people's perception
of the risk of, for example, being on a hijacked
plane or being the victim of a terrorist attack
was also much higher than the real risk as
well.
Speaker 2: Yes.
And you know, what we know is that that if
the consequences are very, you know, imaginable
and scary, you know, again, that that creates
a just thinking about those consequences,
sends a strong feeling of worry or anxiety,
you know, through into our brain.
And then then it doesn't really matter what
the probability is that is that is our brain
can't can't moderate a feeling by a probability
unless you unless that probability is so low
that you could call it zero.
Right.
You don't worry about it.
Well, as long as you got that feeling that's
driven by the consequences, you it feels as
though it's likely and it doesn't matter whether
it's a 1% chance or a ten or a 40%, those
numbers don't matter because you're thinking
of the consequences and you're feeling at
risk.
And we call it probability neglect.
You know, that that we're not sensitive to
to the the different levels of it probability,
even though those are important, you know,
it really makes a difference if the chance
is one in a million or or one in ten, you
know, this sort of thing.
But but it's hard for us where we're going
on our feelings to make those distinctions.
We need to think analytically and and step
away from our feelings and think about, well,
what is this probability, you know, and and
and how likely is it and what's it compare
to other probabilities that we that we encounter
and know something about.
So it's a very complicated dance that our
brain does between feelings and reasoning.
Speaker 1: A couple other things I want to
ask you about.
You mentioned this psychic numbing.
One of the things that you have worked on
and elaborated is this idea of the psychophysical
numbing, the idea that if people hear about
a level of loss of life, for example, that's
an extraordinarily large number, that it actually
becomes more difficult to connect to it, connect
to it on an emotional level.
And one of the things I've talked about from
a media analysis standpoint is that one of
the reasons why a shooting with three victims
gets more media attention than death from
hunger in Africa is that the story has a defined
beginning, middle and end, and that makes
it good for corporate media.
But there's a whole other aspect to this that
relates to your work, which is to some degree,
if you hear 7000 children a day are dying
from hunger, that it's we intuit that it's
an extremely high number, but we're not.
Necessarily connecting to it empirically in
the way that we do to the three shooting deaths
to some degree.
Is that roughly what you have found?
Speaker 2: Yes, we we we have a saying that
that summarizes both what we've found in laboratory
research and what we know from looking outside
our window at what's going on.
And that is that the more who die, the less
we care.
It's a rather startling realization.
And that is, you know, that that that we we
care a lot about individual lives and we'll
do a lot to rescue someone, to protect an
individual, particularly if we're if we if
we know their name, know them personally,
know their names, see their face and so forth.
You get an emotional connection to that, that
life.
And it's very important to protect.
You don't get that emotional connection to
the statistics.
Speaker 1: Right.
Speaker 2: Someone once said Statistics are
human beings with the tears dried off.
No.
And and so you have to you have to to work
at it to think about the individual lives
beneath the surface of those statistics.
Yeah.
Speaker 1: One of the things that some of
these charities that work on hunger in Africa
have done is they tell you that when you make
a contribution, you'll get pictures and information
about the specific person that's being helped
by your donation.
Whether it's true or not, it seems that they're
working on the idea that you're talking about
here.
Speaker 2: Yes, they recognized that, as do
reporters who often, you know, try to, you
know, humanize the story by talking about
individual victims in a larger tragedy like
the school shootings that you see up close
and personal, something about the individual
lives.
And and that that does that does make a difference.
Speaker 1: Last thing I'd like to ask you
about.
You've done work on the I believe it's called
the psychometric paradigm of risk perception,
which relates to if we have positive or negative
feelings about a certain activity, it affects
our perception of how risky it is.
So if, for example, you really like motorcycle
B riding a motorcycle, you might perceive
that it is more safe actually to ride a motorcycle
than it is in reality.
Can you talk a little bit about that?
Speaker 2: Yes, that again, results from our
relying on our feelings as opposed to statistics.
So if if, if, if you like something, you have
a positive feeling towards it, then then it
feels safer.
You know, it feels like the is very beneficial
and the risk is low.
If you dislike something, then you're likely
to view it as high and risk and low in benefit
regardless of what the statistics say.
So for example, with regard to medicines I'm
sorry, with regard to chemicals, there are
chemicals.
We we tend to think are good chemicals like
medicines and bad chemicals like pesticides.
Right.
So we rate pesticides.
We start with our feeling that we dislike
them.
And so we judge them as high and risk and
low and benefit.
Even though pesticides have a lot of benefits.
Same thing with medicines.
We we tend to have more favorable view of
medicines.
So we judge them as very beneficial and low
in risk, even though some medicines can be
very dangerous.
So.
So it starts with our feelings and then we
derive our sense of risk and benefit from
those feelings.
Speaker 1: What's the right way to assess
risk if there is such a sense?
I mean, do we need experts?
Are expert assessments better than a layperson's
or how can we sort of account for all of these
biases?
Speaker 2: The right way is to is to try to
learn when we can trust our feelings and when
we when we can't.
And we just discussed situations.
We can't trust our feelings because when the
number is static, we get statistics that are
large and complex.
The other is we need to we need to rely on
experts, you know.
Absolutely.
We need to to kind of but we also need to
to evaluate what we're hearing with our feelings.
Don't know does does it what the person is
saying?
Does it feel right?
Is there are there sources?
Are there data, you know, does that seem valid
and so forth?
We need both of these ways of thinking what
Kahneman calls fast thinking, you know, with
our gut feelings and slow thinking with, you
know, analysis and trust in experts.
We need to do that.
We need to we need to look for trusted experts
to help us in these complex situations.
Speaker 1: We've been speaking with Dr. Paul
Slovic, who's a professor of psychology at
the University of Oregon.
Really appreciate your insights and your time
today.
Speaker 2: Thank you very much, David.